what would
tim ferriss right now
tell the tim ferriss
who is writing for our work week
knowing right now the success the book
has had how many people it has genuinely
helped and the difference it's made
overall to so many people's lives
i wouldn't say anything to him until he
had finished the book
even then i might say
nothing but if i were to tell him
anything at maybe a few critical
junctures i'd say everything's going to
be okay you can probably get what you
need done
but dial back the anxiety and worry at
least 20
i don't think
tim of 29 would have listened
i would agree but nonetheless maybe i
would say something like that
what i would probably say
to tim at multiple points
is something that came up in tribe of
mentors my last book repeatedly which
was
there have been multiple points where i
have felt like a failure or
have experienced what from
every vantage point objectively looks
like a business failure or a publishing
failure or a huge mistake gigantic [ __ ]
up
and
something that came up a lot in
interviews for the last book was
sometimes you need life
to save you from what you want so you
can get what you need
this is another reason why i now ask so
many people what is your favorite
failure meaning a failure that in
retrospect set you up for a much larger
success later
and
i've really
suffered
from
overly fixating on and worrying about
what seem like or seemed like failures
that's caused me a lot of pain
and
both in the present moment and looking
back at it
and wondering about the persistent
effects of that so-called failure so i i
think i would say hey
i know this seems like catastrophe at
the moment but this is actually
going to
open a door that you can't even imagine
right now to greater opportunities and
that might sound like some [ __ ]
shallow motivational speaker nonsense
like in fact like trust me i can't tell
you what it is just like this is going
to serve you
and
that's true i mean if you look back at
for instance the very difficult
experience which was publishing the
four-hour chef and i won't go into great
detail about this but it was an
incredibly difficult book to write
very proud of it but
almost killed me i mean physically it
was one of the most difficult books to
write put together very complex a lot of
moving pieces
it was because it was published by
amazon
and was the first major acquisition by
what was then announced to be amazon
publishing was boycotted by everybody
barnes noble
indies
big box retailers people wouldn't carry
it
and
it was it was an extremely extremely
painful
let's just say two to three years for me
and i was burned out i was completely
burned out
so i was i was really just depressed and
demoralized and felt like hiding from
the world during and after that
experience
i was so burned out that i decided to
take a break from writing and i decided
to do something lighter because during
the promotion of the four hour chef even
though the book didn't perform the way
i'd wanted it to
i had this experience with a new format
called podcast
and i was
interviewed by mark maron and joe rogan
and the nerdist gang including chris
hardwick and i i had so much fun
during those podcasts and i could be
myself and we could get into the weeds
because it wasn't two to three minutes
on television
i wondered to myself what if i tried
that and just like those guys
edit very minimally
and use it as an opportunity to get
better at asking questions to get rid of
some of my verbal tics
and use it as an excuse to talk to more
interesting people and record it and be
more social because i'm prone to
isolating myself
why not why don't i give that a shot and
try it for six episodes
so if i hadn't had what i considered a
complete catastrophe at the time
this podcast wouldn't exist
which has turned into
something much arguably
much bigger than all of my books
combined
at least based on feedback from
listeners and certainly based on monthly
reach
that's one of many many examples so i
think i would say look just trust me
because i'm your future you so i know
more than you do actually kid
this seems like a mess but
you need life to save you from what you
want sometimes to give you what you
really need and trust me like this
apparent failure is going to give you
like 100x on the flip side just be
[ __ ] patient don't do anything stupid
and self-destructive because you're
really depressed and sad right now
that's what i would say
and how important is that that the
failure can really happen at any point
yeah and when you think about four hour
chef you had two
number one bestsellers at that point and
for our work week i think was on the
best seller list for forever is a good
way to put it yeah like four and almost
five years straight yeah so
knowing that a lot of people associate
failure at the beginning
when they start but the failure can
happen at any point and that resilience
is important how much is that almost
even a lesson that needs to be applied
to four work week if someone is picking
it up or going back or thinking about
giving some of the recommendations a try
i think resiliency as you said it's
something that you've learned but is it
something that you can prepare for as
you try to start something new which is
scary for anyone
there are many ways to practice it in
many ways train yourself
i won't beat a dead horse on stoicism
since i've certainly talked a lot about
it but stoic philosophy seneca and
marcus realize have both been very very
helpful and for those people who have no
familiarity i'm not going to get into it
but you can you can google tao of seneca
i put together a gigantic
compilation that
contains some of my favorite writing
it's available for free as an e-book you
can find it easily tau tao of seneca
but
you know everyone from bill belichick
right competitor supreme
in the in certainly in the football
arena
to george washington thomas jefferson i
mean you go through
prisoners of war
from vietnam war and and other periods
have all cited
or in some fashion actually bill
belichick hasn't personally cited but i
know that the patriots seahawks and so
on at every possible level
uh have consumed stoicism as a means of
competitive advantage
but in terms of developing
resilience
and
tempering emotional reactivity so you
can make better decisions
that's a fantastic tool
it's really a tool kit so that's one
in general i would say on a daily basis
and this is especially true for me in
the last six months
actually with the help of tony robbins
so i've gotten to know over the last few
years and tony's one of those people who
it's easy to be skeptical of tony
uh i've always been a fan i mean my very
first business was a byproduct in part
of listening to personal power to which
i bought used at a used bookstore and
listened to in my crappy hand-me-down
piece of [ __ ] green minivan
which my uh my co-workers affectionately
nicknamed the molester mobile thanks
guys
um not because i'm a molester but
because it was a [ __ ] beat up minivan
that looked like something out of
silence of the lambs and uh got had the
seats stolen out of the back which
didn't help matters the long story
anyway i would get stuck in traffic on
101 in the bay area which anyone who's
done it knows sucks
and listen to tony robbins back and
forth and so it's very largely
responsible for my first business in any
case i've gotten to know tony over the
last few years i've attended two of his
events i've spent a lot of time with him
in person had him on the podcast a
couple times
and he's he's more impressive
the better you get to know him and
what what he really
drove home for me in the last few months
is the importance of trying to identify
your primary question or primary
questions
that you ask yourself
as a means of dictating
behavior and it's very often something
subconscious
so it could be and this is very common
for folks you know am i good enough
or why am i not good enough or what the
[ __ ] wrong with me like these are very
common default questions that
unsurprisingly then result
in many types of debilitating thought
patterns
neuroses
sabotaging behaviors and relationships
whatever it might be
and spending time and tony's the right
guy to look to for direction on that i'm
not gonna do it justice here
but figuring out your default questions
and then
crafting new default questions
so my default question or one of my
default questions now that i try to
revisit on a daily basis because again
you have to practice this stuff it's not
like you just decide write it on a piece
of paper and then your life has changed
forever and your behavior is
upgraded indefinitely no you have to
practice this stuff
is
how can i even more so appreciate this
as a gift
all right and there's
there's there's a bit more nuance to it
but let's let's take a simple version
how can i appreciate this as a gift
and specifically
that is to be used when you are
frustrated when someone is challenging
you when you get an email or a phone
call you hate that throws you into a
tizzy
when things happen that you would
normally look at as a problem
or
perhaps
at best a challenge like how can you
view this as a gift oh you're stuck in
traffic you're gonna miss your flight
okay
this is a chance to practice because
guess what you're missing your [ __ ]
flight no matter what so
how can you view this as a gift
what is this an opportunity to do
uh
that is another way to develop
an ability to reframe quickly
that is incredibly
pragmatic and incredibly effective
for
becoming less reactive and more
able to be
responsible in the sense of response
able you're choosing your response
and that perhaps more than anything else
if you want some semblance of well-being
or feeling of inner peace it is that
it is not by the way i mean if you look
at
a lot of the
noise and craziness right now in the
media cycle
there are many people who are training
themselves and encouraging other people
to try to make everyone in the in the
world change their behavior
to make everyone other than themselves
less offensive
right this is the opposite of making
yourself resilient
it is much more
much more
practical and possible to train yourself
to be less easily offended
to train yourself to reframe so that you
can take people
many of which are never going to change
their behaviors
and repurpose
what they might present you with
as an opportunity or a gift this doesn't
mean you don't call out terrible
behavior doesn't mean that at some
points you don't put on brass knuckles
metaphorically speaking and like deck
someone in the face yeah there are times
when you fight
but if your default is always fighting
not a good approach
you're not going to have the stamina or
the strength to actually
fight the larger necessary fights
and
you're going to exhaust yourself and
you're going to alienate people i
remember a very good friend actually i
won't mention him by name but mutual
friend of ours
said to me at one point who who works
with very very high level players in
many different worlds he's a bit of a
consigliere and he said to be over
dinner once he said
so i was i was laying out all these
various initiatives and causes and so on
i want to pursue in the new year this is
a few years ago and he said
i think you should as a thought exercise
just imagine that you have six bullets
you have a revolver with six bullets and
that's all you get to spend
over the next year or two you have six
things you can take really seriously
and do very publicly that's it
so pick those very wisely which is not
unlike
warren buffett's approach to saying
here's your here's your card
you have 10 hole punches those are the
investments you get to make for the rest
of your life
just as a means of pumping the brakes
and making better decisions i think
that's a a useful
uh useful way to think of things
so those are a few a few things that
come to mind
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you